est-ce que vous m'entendez bien c'est
parfait parce que moi je vais vous
parler de bruits des bruits brut dé son
travail et d sont utiles mon métier
c'est designer sonore industriels mon
métier c'est de créer les sons qui vous
entourent mais en essayant d'apaiser au
maximum votre environnement sonore de
donner du sens aux sont tout simplement
et pourtant je viens d'un petit village
de normandie ou à vrai dire le bruit
n'avait pas sa place à part à quelques
kilomètres je pouvais entendre une
autoroute
rien de plus et encore seulement en
fonction du sens du vent
c'est une chance vous me direz et
pourtant quelques années après je suis
arrivé à paris pour mes études et j'ai
découvert la palette immense que pouvait
m'offrir la machine parisienne mais en
fait j'ai adoré ça tout de suite ça m'a
fasciné
en plus j'avais la chance d'être dans
une université où on pouvait parler de
musique expérimentale de musique
concrète de musique bruitiste
acousmatique et j'ai découvert ça
[Musique]
c'est génial non moi j'ai adoré tout de
suite
à vrai dire je sais pas vraiment
pourquoi ai je pense surtout que ma mère
n'a pas compris pourquoi parce que après
dix ans de chorales et de piano
s'intéresser à ce style de musique ça
dérangeait un petit peu pour
l'information s'était walter ruttmann en
1930 alors tout de suite j'ai pris une
paire de micro et je suis allé à paris
dans le centre ville pendant la nuit et
je suis parti à la chasse aux sons je
restais assise dans l'abribus
j'essayais de de capter le son des des
moteurs de moteurs de bus ensuite
j'allais dans les banques
je devais retirer un petit peu d'argent
mais pour pour aller capter les
engrenages à l'intérieur des
distributeurs de billets et puis ensuite
j'allais dans le métro et j'essayais de
de capter tous les ouvertures de portes
fermeture de portes et son d'annoncer
tour nick et les escalators
j'avais une forme d'euphorie total
j'adorais ça et puis en été pour
rembourser mon prêt étudiant pour
m'acheter une console je sais plus
vraiment mais en tout cas j'ai fait
quelques chantiers et là j'ai découvert
quelque chose de tout à fait différent
j'étais toujours dans l'univers du bruit
mais ça ressemblait plutôt à ça
[Musique]
on dirait presque le genre de
composition que je pouvais faire au
conservatoire à vrai dire
sauf que là ce n'était pas vraiment ça
j'étais simplement en train de faire du
marteau piqueur de la scie circulaire
pour la petite histoire on était en
train de découper des pavés pour faire
des jeux dans une petite école et je me
suis très vite rendu compte de l'effet
très négatif que les bruits avaient sur
moi particulièrement sur mon sommeil je
dormais très très mal j'avais un niveau
d'anxiété toute la journée qui était
maximale et ce qui ma tristesse était
que moi j'avais eu une éducation par
rapport à mon audition et je savais
comment la protéger et ce qui n'était
absolument pas le cas des personnes qui
travaillent avec moi et qui me regardait
en mettant des des bouchons dans les
oreilles en rigolant un petit peu mais
tous ces sons qui nous entourent et qui
nous entoure est en tout cas pendant
pendant cette expérience de chantier il
nous était néanmoins utile parce que
lorsqu'on est en train de découper une
pierre on se rend compte au son de la
discussion va trop vite si on va pas
assez vite
tous ces sons ont une importance
cruciale mais à partir de ce moment là
quand j'ai perçu les faits sur mon corps
je me suis posé la question de la
transformation potentiel de ces sons
mais qui nous sont utiles comme on
pouvait apaiser notre environnement
sonore tout en conservant du sens en
2013 j'ai eu la chance avec mon associé
de travailler sur un projet de sony
fication des véhicules électriques les
véhicules électriques hybrides sont
silencieux par nature en dessous d'une
certaine vitesse imaginez seulement une
seconde une masse d'une tonne projeté à
30 km/heure qui vous foncent dans les
jambes
qu'est ce que ça fait à votre avis ça
fait mal et donc dès les années 2000
quand les premiers véhicules électriques
sont arrivés aux états unis en tout cas
sur les routes publiques
on a des associations de malvoyants qui
ont tiré la sonnette d'alarmé en disant
attention non ce repère à l'oreille et
en dessous de 30 km/heure on n'entend
rien du tout c'est très intéressant
parce que d'un côté on a tout un
historique sur les véhicules à
combustion qui font du bruit on va avoir
des niveaux sonores qui vont enfin
pouvoir s'apaiser
dans l'espace urbain mais non on doit
rajouter du son c'est quelque chose qui
est très intéressant puisqu'on est à la
fois dans un danger potentiel a porté
par une nouvelle technologie aidant un
besoin de rajouter du son et quand je
parle de danger potentiel je parle pas
forcément de la percussion avec la
voiture je parle plutôt des dangers liés
au bruit et notamment penser à ces
personnes qui vivent près d'une route
vous le savez peut-être mais des sons
lorsque vous dormez qui sont à plus de
35 décibels c'est à dire à peine plus
fort qu'une petite conversation comme ça
du bout des lèvres ça va directement
influencé votre pression sanguine et
vous allez donc augmenter le risque
potentiel de faire des crises cardiaques
des sons de plus de 35 décibels pendant
votre sommeil
il ya quelque chose aussi un autre
chiffre qui qui m'interpelle mais qu'il
y ait encore une fois à l'effet je
dirais très perfide des bruits parce que
les bruits encore une donnée très
intéressante mais vont faciliter la
création d'endorphines de noradrénaline
et de cortisone les hormones du stress
et donc naturellement les bruits vont
virer influencer la pression sanguine et
favoriser les crises cardiaques et donc
comment on peut s'en protéger c'est très
très compliqué alors on a trouvé une
solution assez simple néanmoins très
mauvaise
c'est de se protéger de s'isoler en tout
cas avec des bulles de silence
individuelle et donc on met un casque
sur les oreilles et on met la musique à
fond
il faut savoir que l' oms estime à plus
de 1,1 milliard le nombre de personnes
entre 12 et 35 ans qui est en position
de risque d'audition de problèmes
d'audition anticipé et c'est un chiffre
qui est énorme mais simplement par
manque de pédagogie mais aussi parce que
tous les sons qui nous entourent n'ont
jamais été vraiment travaillé jusque là
une question qui m'interpelle c'est
comment travailler c'est son comment
faire quelle question il faut se poser
la première question c'est est-ce que
ces sons sont utiles et ce qu'il nous
donne des informations dont on a besoin
si la réponse est oui on peut passer à
la deuxième question la deuxième
question c'est celle qui à mon sens est
très important c'est celle de
l'esthétique
il faut essayer de créer des sons qui
soit utile certes mais qui en plus vont
être dans des enveloppes agréable on a
la chance no humains en tout cas d'avoir
des capacités de détection des textures
des couleurs des odeurs et notamment des
sons qui est énorme
on est capable de distinguer
l'infiniment petit en terme de
sensations et donc il faut continuer à
jouer avec ça il faut absolument
continuer à jouer avec ça plutôt que de
travailler avec des signaux id c'est
sinusoïde on les entend pour tout et
n'importe quoi je travaille
essentiellement dans l'automobile et je
peux vous dire que peu importe la marque
de voiture vous allez toujours retrouver
c'est pour toutes les fonctionnalités
peu importe la marque il ya donc toute
une éducation à refaire sur cette
dimension une dimension également qui
m'intéresse particulièrement et vous
l'aurez compris c'est celle de l'humain
la dimension humaine est au coeur de mes
recherches est au coeur de ma pensée
j'ai eu la chance de travailler avec des
malvoyants sur l'orientation dans des
villes qui leur sont inconnus
parce que c'est une vraie problématique
j'ai pu travailler également avec des
personnes atteintes d'alzheimer
j'ai compris que tous ces sons lors été
extrêmement utiles et que donc essayer
de les supprimer au maximum n'avait plus
vraiment grand sens une expérience que
j'aimerais partager avec vous c'est
celle des hôpitaux
vous avez tous peut-être eu ce malheur
je dirais d'aller dans les hôpitaux de
détecter tous les sons qui peuvent vous
déranger à l'intérieur des salles des
salles d'opération à l'intérieur des des
salles d'urgence
le respirateur tous les petits bips bips
bips des machines j'aimerais simplement
peut-être vous rafraîchir la mémoire
[Musique]
si vous entendez ça alors que vous êtes
branché simplement perfusé vous avez
peut-être un peu l'impression mourir
alors qu'en fait c'est pas forcément le
cas pour le médecin il peut tout
simplement s'agir d'un retour d'un
biofeedback comme on dit d'un retour sur
une donnée enfin particulière
aujourd'hui je travaille avec un hôpital
parisien sur une salle de prix
opérations en chirurgie orthopédique
cette salle est particulièrement
affreuse elle est en sous sol vous avez
un design inexistant je ne peux même pas
dire que c'est du design c'est du béton
un petit peu et cahiers avec de la
peinture écaillée un petit peu partout
et surtout on a la chance quand on
attend sa propre opération d'entendre
l'opération qui se déroule juste à côté
sauf que en chirurgie orthopédique on va
pas faire des petites injection comme ça
c'est plutôt le marteau le burin la scie
circulaire
donc vous imaginez un petit peu le la
charge mentale qui montent comme ça un
petit peu avant l'opération et donc on
travaille sur des ambiances sonores pour
apaiser des patients avant cette
opération mais finalement c'est
quasiment impossible parce que l'humain
va synthétiser toutes les émotions
qu'ils détectent un instant t
c'est à dire que ce qu'il va percevoir
avec ses yeux avec ses mains avec la
langue et avec les oreilles vont créer
une émotion unique et si tous les sens
ne sont pas je dirais excité dans une
même direction
vous allez créer ce qu'on appelle un 2
perceptuelle une distorsion émotionnel
alors autant vous dire que cette
ambiance sonore aussi agréable soit elle
est quasiment impossible à faire
transparaître comme tel auprès du
patient tant l'environnement général et
désagréable
donc pour reprendre un petit peu les
termes de jean ann fraser dans une
précédente conférence
il disait que les architectes devraient
penser un petit peu plus avec leurs
oreilles et moi j'aimerais tout
simplement généralisée et faire un appel
à tous les créateurs les ingénieurs les
designers les chercheurs à pousser
derrière les financeurs car finalement
tout se fait aussi avec de l'argent mais
a poussé à réfléchir un petit peu plus
avec l'humain au centre de nos
préoccupations et à penser un petit peu
plus avec nos oreilles pour apaiser nos
environnements sonores et donner du sens
aux sons merci à vous
[Applaudissements]